en 1888 paul gauguin révolutionne la
peinture avec cette nature morte qu'il
intitule fait gloanec du nom de
l'auberge dans laquelle il séjourne à
pont-aven en bretagne cet été là pour un
anniversaire de la gérante le 15 août
il décide d'offrir un tableau qui
dépassera toutes ces recherches
préalables
il prend pour modèle les estampes
japonaises cloisonnant les couleurs sur
une surface plane peu sûr du succès que
rencontrera son tableau il décide de le
signer du nom de madeleine bernard soeur
du peintre emile bernard avec qui y
séjournent chez les gloanec le tableau
révolutionnera littéralement la peinture
et ouvrira la voie à une nouvelle école
les nabis il restera dans la collection
de madame gloanec jusqu'à sa mort avant
d'être racheté par maurice denis
disciple de paul gauguin
il a pu entrer dans les collections du
musée des beaux-arts d'orléans dans les
années 70 grâce aux dommages de guerre
et il est aujourd'hui une des oeuvres
les plus importantes du musée
[Musique]